the jurgen experience and you've got
your social engineering aspect of it and
the social engineering aspect of it
is it's very problematic for me um there
was an article that was written recently
and one of the guys he was saying
something about me
and that no silencing white nationalism
and keeping them off your platform is
not censorship
which is the the dumbest way
to sort of boil down my position
on censorship and
ignore the real problems of other people
deciding what someone can or can't say
and what is or is not offensive one of
the best examples is a woman named
uh i think this is morgan murph megan
murphy megan murphy who's her name
she's a what's called a trans exclusion
exclusive
exclusionary what's the word why are
exclusionary trans-exclusionary radical
feminists like turf
and she was in a debate with i don't
blame you for not being able to remember
that
trans-exclusionary but exclusionary is a
weird word she was in a debate
with people about whether or not trans
women
should be able to invade feminist
women's spaces so a person who's
biologically male yeah who becomes a
female later in life
should be able to make decisions in
feminist
debates and decisions right and get into
their sport so she
says yes the sports is the big one for
me particularly fighting
yeah she says but a man is never a woman
this is what she says okay so twitter
asked her to take it down
so she takes a screenshot of that she
takes it down takes a screenshot of it
and reposts it like [ __ ] you
like i'm gonna put it back up again this
way they banned her for life
for life you know who's on twitter with
no problems
oj simpson oj simpson murdered two
people
he [ __ ] went to jail for armed
kidnapping
and he's on tv he's on every day hello
to the world
he's fine among other things too this is
megan murphy she says a man is not a
woman she's
[ __ ] correct biologically she's
biologically correct i mean if we want
to decide
socially and culturally that we we're
going to accept this person as a woman
this is a completely different
discussion
but she's right she's biologically
correct the scientists would say well
here we go we've got some chromosomes
here we've got x and y this is a penis
as a vagina this is a man that's a woman
and you know maybe this person
identifies with being a woman but she's
saying you're not a woman
and you're banning her for life it's
this is crazy
this is that culture in its most boiled
down form it has nothing to do with
white nationalism
it has nothing to do with race it has to
do with a person
that feels like their own particular
protected group being a feminist being a
woman
and and trying to like carve out
rules where women are protected and
she's saying well i don't like the fact
that these
trans women are entering into the space
and dominating it in certain aspects
right and it's it's an example of this
intersectional coalition that they've
created
yes coming coming to terms with itself
and you know the a lot of the feminist
groups aligned with us
against the equality act because the
equality act would have put in into real
practice this
in into concrete terms uh biological men
getting into women's sports
yes and so a lot among other things by
the way that that
and a lot of feminist groups were
finally coming out and saying no this is
not
correct like we we we're a feminist
group so let's protect
women which i fully agree with and
but you know on a deeper level it's
interesting to watch that intersectional
coalition just
implode and it stems from this desire on
their part to
to divide everybody up into three
categories of oppressed uh the
oppressors
and then the champions of the oppressed
right and the woke culture is the
champions of course
that's how they label themselves they
they label their intersectional
coalition
as the oppressed and then they lump and
then they have this whole other kind of
intersectional coalition of oppressors
and they connect it all with the worst
of the worst which is white supremacists
nazis and so you're all and they say
you're all connected with that
somehow even even if you're just making
a
a pretty bland statement about
biological men and women
somehow that connects to this and this
is how you see them reason their way
through it
and uh and what what that does is it
undercuts
real basic arguments because you're
attacking the intent of that argument
because you're connecting it with the
worst of the worst right we kill nazis
that's what our country does we did it
and so if you're connecting all of these
things you disagree with with that well
you don't have to make an argument
anymore
yes and the idea that you're going to
somehow or another convince people that
everyone is a nazi just because you say
so that's not going to work
yeah what's going to work is people are
going to just they're going to go to the
other side
you're making more republicans with this
crazy talk you you're well i hope so
well
that's really what's going on i mean my
friend chris pratt wore a t-shirt that
said don't tread on me i don't remember
that
what the [ __ ] man it's a it's a goddamn
ancient flag
representing our separation from england
and
our our want to be able to start our own
country i mean that's what it was
it yeah exactly and it gets to a deeper
culture war
one of there's many fronts on the
cultural wars this is a big one
is america based on bad things or good
things are we good
intrinsically good or are we bad this is
this is a huge
fissure in the culture war right now and
uh you know
when when we and i and i have a lot of
fear that
that that these things are boiling up
and that we're destroying the things
the few things that hold us together you
know as a country like what makes us
americans it's it's not ethnicity it's
not religion
it's not even really geographic area
because our geographic area has changed
over time
it is it is ideals it is ideals and
those ideals are symbolized by certain
things and that's the uss con
the us constitution the declaration of
independence the pledge of allegiance
the flag
uh the national anthem like these things
matter and
i think they're very important for a
culture and
and be and this actually all ties back
into this sort of oppressor oppressed
kind of ideology because if you tell
people that they're oppressed well then
they have to look for an oppressor
and that starts small it starts with
your parent or your boss or somebody you
don't like okay it's their fault that's
why i have something bad happen to me
it's somebody else's fault
then it grows into groups okay now you
get into identity politics and putting
identities against each other
then you're starting to blame
institutions okay and this is kind of
the
this is this is when we talk about
bernie sanders this is he's doing this
often he's blaming institutions for our
for
for our issues constantly that has met
him that has morphed into blaming the
entire country
the entire country as a as an american
ideal is to blame i i just think that's
really both
i think it's historically inaccurate i
think it's inaccurate objectively
but i i just think it's dangerous i
don't think it can go anywhere good
unless you just want total revolution
which
i think some people do um it just it
tears us apart
right and we're getting divided along
we're we're
we're allowing the pop culture to get
involved in this too so we can't share
pop culture anymore
uh because you know musicians are
getting involved in politics and
comedians and
late night shows and it's like okay well
now half the country can't even watch it
because those people are just telling
them how stupid they are
yeah we're losing these basic symbols
that bring us together
and then we're also losing the pop
culture that kind of brings us together
that should be something we can just
share
and then not talk politics but that's
been removed as well and i just the
the culture war is it it's it's not
going a good direction
i'm hoping that this is an adolescent
stage in the development of this strange
country that's an experiment
self-government that's what i'm thinking